my hero academia it goes by many names
some call it boku no hero academia I
don't talk to those people other people
know it as that show that has that one
song but we on this channel
affectionately refer to it as what marks
not doing a Dragon Ball video guys
what's going on
mark you [ __ ] traitor but more
importantly today we are discussing two
individuals in the blue corner weighing
in at a scrawny 90 pounds soaking wet we
have is a goof Vittoria having spent his
entire life being all mites biggest
stand through demonstrating his sheer
determination and heroism found himself
as the recipient of the stockpiled ultra
clerk one for all bestowing unto him all
of all mites abilities say that ten
times fast in the somatically
appropriate red corner stands the
brooding lean chiseled this is getting
weird he's fifteen koski baku go upon
discovering his explosive quark as a
young child this spiky haired character
has been held in high regard by all
those that surround him he has a strong
sense of self and knows what his goals
are and today we are attempting to
compare these two characters in a world
of superpowers billion-dollar man-made
battleground cities and a flamboyant
villain society hell-bent on world
domination we are attempting a
discussion on who you yes you might
prefer to be if given the choice the
explosive baku co or the incredibly
strong midoriya how might you ask will
we be deciding this by of course
applying real-world psychology and
philosophy to an animated show set in an
alternative superhero reality aimed at
teenage boys that live in japan so as my
grandmother would say let's [ __ ] do
this [ __ ] the overarching theme of my
hero academia is that of heroism and to
what lengths those heroes will sacrifice
themselves in the name of what is right
Joss Whedon said the thing about being a
hero is even when it doesn't look like
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
he's going to keep digging he's going to
keep trying to do right and make up for
what's gone before just because that's
who he is and he made the Avengers so he
knows his [ __ ] and Hulk
smash so let's take a look at Vidura and
bak ago using those parameters growing
up in the same neighborhood midoriya and
bak ago became childhood friends with a
mutual admiration of all night he's
basically this universe as Superman
however as it is the case for most young
kids in the my hair academia world Baku
co-developed his very own quirk that
from the get-go puts his potential for
becoming a hero far above that of
everyone else around him especially
midoriya who is faced with the
unfortunate reality that he will be
corkulous so while back ago was being
heralded as the second coming of Christ
among his peers midoriya does even have
the support of his own mother so right
from the get-go these two are dealing
with vastly different expectations and
realities everyone in baka goes world
thinks he can do no wrong and midoriya
is left feeling sorry for himself
however this small interaction acts as a
microcosm for both of these characters
outlooks and philosophies baka ko isn't
angry that majora is being nice here
he's insulted that anyone specifically
midoriya thought he wasn't perfectly
fine Baco isn't embarrassed that he fell
he's embarrassed that midoriya thought
he could help him in any way Tabaka go
weaknesses were the worst qualities
anyone can have fast forward like 10
years in both midoriya and baka go have
grown apart baka go views midoriya as a
shining example of everything he hates
weakness midoriya on the other hand
while acknowledging the odds of him ever
becoming a hero is unlikely has
diligently kept detailed records of
every hero he deemed to be worth
studying while still having his heart
set on applying to the most prestigious
school the area you a I wanted you to
see what real courage is instead of
getting the idea that courage is a man
with a gun in his hand it's when you
know you're licked before you begin but
you begin anyway and see it through no
matter what Atticus Finch this quote
holds completely true for midoriya when
faced with this horrible situation Baku
ko
someone who torments about a daily basis
is being attacked by a villain having
just been told by his idol of all people
that he shouldn't commit to being a hero
due to his lack of a quirk right now
midoriya is at a life time low for as
long as you can remember he has been
told though that he can't do
and that he shouldn't do it but that
doesn't matter not to him because as the
show puts it his feet moved without him
thinking a large crowd of people a bunch
of other heroes and even attired all
might are looking on in distress as Baca
go is overwhelmed by this creature but
midoriya the one without the powers
without the know-how the one who was
told over and over again that he could
never achieve his dream was the only one
courageous enough heroic enough to try
the world is a dangerous place not
because of those who do evil but because
of those that look on and do nothing
Albert Einstein it was because of these
actions the rest of the heroes and all
night decided to dig deep and take
charge because of Midori a--'s actions
in this moment midoriya became a hero
something important to take away from
this however is that Baku go despite
getting all of the praise for the
incident was deeply upset by it baka go
does not care what other people around
him think he cares only what he believes
to be true and while he doesn't
appreciate what midoriya did for him he
does now hold him in a higher regard
never again tormenting him it was due to
this act that midoriya was chosen as all
might successor he inherited all of his
powers worked hard to train his body and
arrived on time for the UA entrance
exams like baka CO and the other
hopefuls I won't go into too much detail
regarding these two and their individual
performances but one thing I will say
once again midoriya was shown to value
the individual more than anything that's
important to him even if it meant
sacrificing his opportunity to go to the
school of his dreams and letting down
his childhood hero that takes guts again
that's what makes a true hero
ibaka go on the other hand got through
on raw talent alone scoring almost twice
as high the villain points of any of the
other examinees from here on out I'm
going to be going through the rest of
the story between these two much faster
I'll be touching only on their most
significant points all right since the
beginning of this series up until this
point neither Bach ago or midoriya have
interacted much outside of some bullying
and flashbacks it's here Bach ago learns
that midoriya in fact has a quirk and
those believes that midoriya had been
pulling the wool over his eyes this
entire time when she doesn't love Bukka
go wanted to be the only person from his
school to be accepted and now Midori had
made that impossible and so now is the
perfect time to size up Victoria while
letting off some much-needed steam
during this time midoriya is wearing a
green bunny rabbit to give a costume
type thing while crapping his pants if
he had any the fight is great but the
sections I want to draw attention to are
the following when faced with baka go
midoriya stands up to him declaring that
he's the deku who always does his best
immediately baka go is faced with that
familiar attitude from midoriya that
despite being terrified at quality Baca
Co associates with weakness majora
always stands there with his feet
planted firmly on the ground ready to
fight for what he believes on the flip
side
Victoria demonstrates his ability to
take in all necessary information while
coming up with the best possible
solution on the spot this I think is
Midori his superpower he demonstrates an
awareness that none of his other
classmates possess including baka Goku
at this point is a much more skilled
fighter
however despite making this split-second
decision resulting in his team's victory
notorious performance has some severe
drawbacks he was incredibly reckless
after this midoriya confronts Papago
with the guilt of his borrowed power of
weighing heavily on his shoulders bak
ago takes this as a sign midoriya is
showing pity towards him admitting to
himself and to midoriya that he has a
lot of work to do but that one day he
will be the best he even goes as far as
to claim that one day he will surpass
all mice
life is 10% what you experience and 90%
how you respond to it Dorothy
M Ned Amer a significant amount of time
has passed in the series at this point
this interaction takes place after us J
after the sports festival and after the
stain incident midoriya has since worked
closely with Gran Torino and has
uncovered a way to use 5% of his power
without risk of damage to his body
enough of that back on track we're at
the end of your exam baka go and Madore
had been paired together against all
might who is playing the villain role
the object of this exercise is one for
at least one individual from the hero
team to get through the door on the
opposite side of the battlefield or to
to apprehend the villain which is in
this case all might need I remind you
however despite the rules of this exam
being clear neither Bosco or midoriya
can agree on a course of action and
instead get in each other's way midoriya
wishing to flee bak ago insisting to
stand and fight I am NOT talented I am
obsessed Conor McGregor to someone like
Baca go heroes win no matter the
circumstance no matter how
insurmountable the odds similar to
Midori Ibaka ko has always idolized all
mine held him in the highest regard
however unlike midoriya he can look past
all might unto what might be midoriya on
the other hand can only see all mine he
is his ceiling this exam shows a ton of
both characters offsites midoriya when
faced with the split-second decision
crossing the line winning the match or
saving Baku go ops to save Baku go with
what we could only assume is a broken
back
however Baco shows more grit in this one
interaction than most characters in a me
show demonstrate absorbing punches to
the point of vomiting pushed to the edge
of collapse he still does everything in
his power going as far as to bite all
might to achieve his goal because that
is what heroes do they never give up
they win
[Music]
this interaction takes place right after
the kidnapping of Bach ago and the hero
licensing exam seemingly out of nowhere
Bakugan is a challenge to midoriya would
on one combat after-school unsanctioned
at this moment in time midoriya is
feeling an incredible sense of sorrow
guilt and insecurity about his abilities
to be the symbol of peace replacing all
my it's something that's clearly
consumed him since all meit's retirement
bach ago is the type of character that
is usually very upfront and honest but
never shares more than he needs to
however in this scene his emotions
overflow this is the most raw and
vulnerable we have ever seen Bach ago in
this series up until this point speaking
about his frustrations and struggling
with the notion midoriya was the one
chosen by all mine I don't think it's by
accident that this scene almost exactly
mirrors Midori is seen with all my back
in season one however totally they're
opposites in midoriya scene he's
overcome with emotion because all my
chose him in Bacau scene he's overflowed
with emotion because all my did not
choose him going as far as to question
whether or not his admiration of the
hero was wrong despite not being
naturally gifted in combat midoriya is
gifted by being who he is a person who
while scared can stand up for what's
right and always make the best decision
in the moment something baku go thinks
is a major shortcoming of his he was the
reason his team lost in the first battle
he wasn't capable enough to escape the
league of villains and was captured but
on top of all of that Baku now blames
himself for all mites retirement for the
first time we hear Bach goes voice
without its usual grit these are his
honest feelings our minor that he liked
midoriya is still only a kid who more
than anything else in the world wants to
be an amazing hero like all my when the
series began it became clear that Bach
ago and midoriya were vastly different
people but as it progressed while still
different the information revealed about
them has led me to believe that they are
much more alike than what is seen at
face value they are two sides of the
same hero coin midoriya admires Bach ago
because he possesses physical natural
instinct that he will never have without
tremendous effort baka acknowledges
Midori as someone who has a quality that
he might not ever possess either
altruistic courage a quality that gain
the notice of all might someone he'd
idolized his entire life baka Co is an
angry person because he is always
measuring himself against who he thinks
is better midoriya is an unassuming
person constantly second-guessing
himself because he believes others are
bettering midoriya is the heart of a
hero in baku go is the action of a hero
but before all of that they are both two
teenagers who have put a tremendous
amount of pressure on their own
shoulders because of who they want to be
they have different ideas of what they
think it might take to be that but in
reality they are both right and wrong at
the same time but baka Co might have
started out really wrong though I mean
he was like a budding serial killer at
the beginning of the show but then again
the negative side of midoriya was
highlighted also and throughout the
series both have come closer and closer
to holding the same ideals so I ask you
who would you rather be who do you think
you're more like leave a comment down
below and let me know until next time
guys I've been totally not mark thank
you so much for watching
[Music]